[Music]
music is important to me it's always
been a wonderful support for me and a
real support for me with my characters
and and helping me fine-tune and find it
in with with these people when I make a
playlist I think you want to be very
conscious of the vibe and the tone that
you're trying to set one of my when my
favorite jay-z songs that I always go
back to was the Lord
oh no but every time I felt bad was dad
called me right back
he drove me right back in some way he
embodies this is what it is to to make
it to go from the projects to the
policies a very specific and unique
version of the American Dreams then
listening to a lot of instrumental music
right now so there's a producer out of
LA by the name of knowledge he has a
wonderful song called time and tide he's
got several really great albums but that
song time and tide it just feels like
summer summer is buoyant it's up
[Music]
I'll cooling the gang summer madness
which we all know from Will Smith having
sampled
hi this coyote was it knock amaro into
the Sun rise garden the sky cream
rickets America Baidu of course here are
dynamite think has a new album that is
out you still go through things in the
summer so you want to leave room on that
mixtape to tap into to people who are
coming out of something or shedding
something farming love slum village any
time I listen to J Dilla there there's a
joy but there's always a little hint of
sadness there for me because I think
they just bring up memories for me in
general about about the culture and when
hip-hop has sort of contributed to my
life being a nothing he embodied it
these are just all songs all music that
I feel like has a real vibe the real
buoyancy to it you I want to put things
together
or there's a nice flow
[Music]